here's here's the The Awful Truth about  Iran is that there are a lot of ways  that we could label it that it's a  Theocratic regime or that it's a fascist  regime or that it's like a military  regime  but the truth of the matter is that like  most autocratic States  it's impossible to really know who's in  charge of what right the the person in  charge of your life is the guy on the  other side of the desk  you know if he's a bureaucrat yeah if  he's had a nice lunch  and uh and you know had a nice  conversation with his wife then maybe  you're okay if he had a fight with his  wife then you're screwed and and it's  not like you can point to the law to say  but that's not how it works right  um in countries like Iran the law is  whatever the person in front of you says  the law is